zusammen herzlich willkommen zu zdf
heute live und ihrem live stream zu
aktuellen diskussionen und ereignissen
und seit gestern gilt es verlängerte
kontakt beschränkungen strengere
maßnahmen härtere regeln alles das in
landkreisen wo es höhere
infektionszahlen gibt als im rest von
deutschland ab 200 infektionen in den
letzten sieben tagen wird darüber
diskutiert dass man dann diese maßnahmen
erlassen soll das sind ja geht es dir
das corona gipfels von gestern
viele maßnahmen aber sie zum beispiel
private zusammenkünfte lassen sich
überhaupt gar nicht vernünftig
kontrollieren andere wären
kontrollierbar zum beispiel die masken
pflicht im öffentlichen raum oder
öffentliche zusammenkünfte
aber die frage ist sind die kapazitäten
dafür überhaupt da
und wenn man einmal nach gestern schaut
ins thüringische hildburghausen
dann müssen wir feststellen geht so da
sind rund 400 menschen singend durch die
kreisstadt im süden von thüringen
gezogen das ist nahe der bayerischen
grenze als spaziergang wo sie diese
unangemeldete demo da tituliert die
menschen trugen keine masken hielten
sich nicht an abstandsregeln der
organisator des ganzen ist unklar
das jetzt es gab aufrufe in sozialen
netzwerken sich dort zu versammeln
die polizei versuchte die menschen dann
aufzuhalten und aufzulösen war aber nur
mit 30 beamtinnen vor ort sie hielt die
versammelten aber davon ab in richtung
der bundesstraße 89 zu gehen dabei kam
es dann auch zum einsatz von
pfefferspray nach zwei stunden war diese
kroner partie dann vorbei insgesamt gab
es 30 anzeigen gegen wegen verstoß gegen
das infektionsschutzgesetz alles
parallel zu den beratungen von bund und
ländern gestern abend und heute hat das
lka dann für diesen landkreis eine neue
farbe eingeführt auf der korona hotspot
karte den letzten sieben tagen gab es
dort nämlich über 600 neue infektionen
pro 100000 einwohner meiner kollegin
melanie haack ist für uns vor ort in
hildburghausen
was war denn da gestern bitte los ja
also ich stehe hier auf dem marktplatz
von hildburghausen wir sehen dass hinter
uns ist das
rathaus es begann um 19 uhr eine
versammlung so war es genannt von 400
menschen und wir haben mit vielen heute
sprechen können auch mit dem
bürgermeister der sagt es waren alle
dabei also familien mit kerzen wir haben
uns auch viele bilder angeschaut es war
im grunde eine ganz bunte mischung der
menschen die hier gestern unterwegs war
wie gesagt familienmenschen hielten auch
transparente hoch und es hieß hände weg
von unseren kindern wie gesagt der
initiator ist bislang nicht auszumachen
das sagt auch die polizei die hier mit
30 beamten vor ort war
so war die situation hier gestern abend
bis etwa 23 uhr als die veranstaltung
hier aufgelöst wurde und man muss sagen
klar sie ist klar untersagt und gerade
hier in hildburghausen mit derzeit fast
600 drei infizierten pro 100000
einwohnern
das wollte ich gerade sagen das ist ja
kein normaler kann vielleicht neues wo
du gerade bist burghausen ist ein
wirklicher airport in deutschland
dort gelten ja auch schon länger
schärfere kontakt beschränkungen kannst
das noch mal vielleicht genau erklären
was dort erlaubt und was verboten ist ja
genau das macht die situation auch so
schwierig ist es insgesamt auch eine
sehr überstrapazierte und gereizte
stimmung gestern war dass das
ordnungsamt vor ort mitarbeiter vom
landkreis es wurde sehr aggressiv ihr
reagiert sie sprachen auch davon dass
sie beschimpft wurden denn es ist so
dass seit gestern seit mittwoch hier
eine neue allgemein verordnung gilt für
den landkreis thüringen und die geht
streng über die maßnahmen in thüringen
und auch bundesweit hinaus und der
wesentliche punkt dabei ist eigentlich
dass die menschen ab jetzt ihre wohnung
und ihr grundstück nur noch verlassen
wollen wenn sie wichtige dinge zu tun
haben das ist der gang zum arzt zur
arbeit oder wenn sie wichtige dinge
einkaufen das heißt somit es gibt keinen
anderen grund seine wohnung oder das
grundstück zu verlassen gleichzeitig
gelten natürlich die abstandsregeln und
schärfere mund nasenschutz regeln und
das ist das problem in der gemengelage
in der man sich hier eben derzeit auch
befindet und hinzu kommt dass seit
gestern die schulen geschlossen sind und
auch die kindergärten und damit sind
rund 8000 kinder jetzt zu hause und das
ist eine maßnahme die seit gestern
morgen gilt und am montag hat man sich
hier zusammen mit der landesregierung
dazu entschieden eben schulen und
kindergärten komplett zu schließen
so jetzt habe ich hier schon eine schöne
frage auf youtube von trulli ita liebe
männer nicht wir haben uns gerade noch
drüber unterhalten miteinander solltest
du die maske tragen oder nicht
ich habe gesagt setzt sie doch bitte
auch weil wir immer wieder nachfragen
kriegen
warum wir sie nicht tragen sie möchte
jetzt wissen warum sie auf fast du bist
doch allein also ist einfach ja ich
glaube man muss sie nicht tragen dort in
hildburghausen aber es ist ein bisschen
einfach mal eine signalwirkung gewesen
von unserer seite aus
ja genau man trägt sieht oder man soll
sie jetzt nach der neuen allgemeinen
verordnung draußen tragen wenn man sich
beispielsweise auf dem marktplatz
befindet dort wo sich menschen näher
kommen und wir machen das einfach wir
sind ja einfach in einem hotspot als
kleines kamerateam unterwegs und
deswegen entscheide ich mich dazu die
maske auch zu tragen du hast wir uns die
menschen gestern vor ort oder heute vor
ort gefragt was sie von den maßnahmen
und von den protesten gestern halten und
das haben sie uns geantwortet
bei dem früher schon maßnahmen passieren
müssen
um die bürger zu schützen ausgangsverbot
geschäfte trotzdem offen
ich weiß nicht ob das so viel sinn und
zweck hat vorgestern zum beispiel stand
ich acht stunden hier mit 0 kundschaft
wo sonst am tag mindestens zehn elf
zwölf zahlende kunden kommen wenn er
halt dass diese bewohner zahlen nicht
nach unten gehen muss sollte dieser
drastische schritt gegangen werden ist
einfach einfach so ich finds richtig
gestern das fand ich absolut schrieb die
demonstrationen also ich schäme mich da
eigentlich für leute aus hilfe kaufen
weil ich arbeite im krankenhaus und ich
weiß nicht wie man jetzt immer noch
corona leugnen kann ich sehe es jeden
tag und ich habe dafür wirklich null
verständnis geben das nicht in ordnung
weil ganz viele leute ohne maske und
dicht an dicht laufen hier
das ist falsch grundsätzlich falsch aber
die leute die ihn frustriert walzer
allgemein ärger haben und dieser ärger
wettern bei demonstrationen will
bildhausen leipzig berlin geht wieder
raus
tja also frustrierte bürger in
hildburghausen melanie haack ist für uns
vor ort wenn eine die behörden china
gestern aber auch so ein bisschen
überfordert zu sein
ja das muss man sagen und das wurde hier
auch teilweise eingestanden es waren 30
beamte der polizei und der bürgermeister
sagte damals zu uns auch ein fachmann
hat auch mittlerweile in sämtlichen
behörden ob bei polizei feuerwehr bei
den einsatzkräften im krankenhaus zum
einen viele fälle von menschen die in
quarantäne sind und von personen die an
cupid 19 erkrankt sind weshalb man auch
gestern hier nicht mehr polizisten
aufbieten konnte und eben auch nicht in
der lage war die diesen aufzug früher zu
unterbinden immerhin waren es fast drei
stunden in denen die menschen hier
unterwegs waren
und das hat man hier heute auch
eingestanden du hast auch
den bürgermeister von hildburghausen
herrn kohmann gefragt was da gestern los
war und woran es lag und der hat uns
folgendes geantwortet war im vorfeld
nicht absehbar wie viele menschen kommen
ich war auch fassungslos über die große
zahl und ich gehe davon aus dass beim
nächsten mal dann noch mehr
einsatzkräfte zur verfügung stehen fakt
ist wir haben auch hier in der
polizeiinspektion erkrankte polizisten
also auch da ist nicht mehr volle
einsatzstärke freunden und das merkt man
natürlich auch bei der umsetzung solcher
dinge das heißt im klartext wenn nicht
genug leute vorhanden sind vor ort
melanie dann können die demonstranten
oder können menschen machen was sie
wollen na ja ganz so ist es nicht man es
ist einfach die problematik in diesem
landkreis dass sowohl die einzelnen
städte als auch die der landrat die
verwaltung hier massiv am limit sind
massiv überfordert sind und weshalb man
eben das personal bindet seit wochen
seit wochen steigen die zahlen ja auch
dramatisch für die kontakt
nachverfolgung für wahnsinnig viele
dinge die damit in verbindung stehen das
auch so klassische verwaltungsarbeiten
jetzt mittlerweile auch liegen bleiben
müssen
und gestern war auch das problem einfach
wer hat die kompetenz wofür also die
polizei kann jetzt verweise aussprechen
kann solche dinge tun aber die frage ist
wer verschickt am ende ein
bußgeldbescheid oder die entsprechende
strafe und das ordnungsamt kann es nicht
alleine ist es angewiesen hier auf das
gesundheitsamt und das gesundheitsamt
gehört zum landratsamt weil es eben eine
allgemeinverfügung hier für diesen
landkreis ist die hier gilt und daran
sieht man wie schwierig die situation
auch ist allein bei den kompetenzen und
zwischen den behörden hier der lage herr
zu werden also zu wenig personal es gab
auch glaube ich das eingeständnis von
herrn kummer dass man zu wenig
kommunikation hatte der maßnahmen kannst
du das noch genauer ausführen
ja das ist so ein bisschen ein thema das
ich glaube ich aber dass auch zu viel
frustration geführt hat das thema
kommunikation und das hat er auch
eingestanden weil den menschen oft nicht
klar ist was kommt jetzt und was kommt
wann ein beispiel ist das thema
schulschließung das ist
hier im landkreis seit zwei wochen in
der diskussion kommt sie oder kommt sie
nicht und so eine schulschließung kann
nur erfolgen in rücksprache mit der
landesregierung und da hat man erst mal
abgewartet weil das ziel war schulen und
kindergärten so lange wie möglich offen
zu lassen und das ist eine diskussion
die eltern die berufstätig ist hier seit
wochen mit verfolgen und die frage
natürlich ist was passiert jetzt und
jetzt war am montag hier beispielsweise
clokey wir werden die schulen ab
mittwoch schließen aber wie wann was
genau folgt war für die eltern selbst am
abend davor noch nicht klar
und auch jetzt ist es schwierig
abzusehen wann die kinder hier wieder
zur schule gehen können
geplant ist ja jetzt ein sehr sehr
flächendeckender sehr großer massentest
mit 11.000 schnelltests die hier heute
und morgen ankommen sollen
im landratsamt und mit diesen 11.000
tests will man die kinder testen
freiwillig ein test der freiwillig
erfolgen soll aber sie wollen jetzt hier
mit ab kommendem dienstag so ist stand
jetzt die planung mit unterstützung der
bundeswehr und auch mit freiwilligen
testern aus anderen behörden vom land
eben hier die kinder und jugendlichen
testen um sofort ein ergebnis zu haben
und dann sagen zu können wer kann danach
möglicherweise in der nächsten woche
wieder zurück zur schule oder in den
kindergarten
aber auch hier zeigt sich dass das ein
immenser aufwand ist für einen landkreis
für die einzelnen städte das jetzt
umzusetzen also in den schulen jetzt
listen anzufertigen wer gehört in welche
klasse welche klasse welche schule
welcher ort wird wann getestet das ist
jetzt ein enormer aufwand und deswegen
kann man jetzt auch noch gar nicht klar
sagen die die allgemeinverfügung gilt
jetzt zwar bis zum 13
dezember aber was genau bis dann gilt
und ab wann und wie die kinder wieder
zur schule gehen das ist noch offen
deshalb heißt es bis dahin jetzt erst
mal dass die kinder zu hause
unterrichtet werden und wie gesagt in
der nächsten woche will man hier mit
dieser test strategie auch wieder den
überblick bekommen über die situation
weil es mittlerweile es begann ende
oktober und mittlerweile
ist es so dass man nicht mehr sagen kann
woher de oder quellen sind also worauf
man schauen soll wo man jetzt explizit
eingreifen soll deswegen kommt man jetzt
an den schulen dass man die kinder da so
erhoffen sie es sich hier schnell wieder
in die einrichtungen zurückbringen kann
und sonst guckt man ja stück für stück
und deswegen ist natürlich der druck
auch so hoch dass sich die menschen hier
an die maßnahmen halten und da sagte
auch bürgermeister kummer noch mal ein
wichtiger punkt ist einfach dass die
menschen im privaten leben im privaten
sich auch an diese maßnahmen halten
wenn dann die vielen dank an sind wir
gespannt was in hildburghausen und in
südthüringen da weiter vor sich geht
hoffen wir dass es mit den zahlen runter
geht heute abend vielen dank zu dir
die schwierige kommunikation schwierige
durchsetzung von maßnahmen das dürfte
unser nächster gesprächsgast auch ganz
gut kennen erst nämlich präsident des
deutschen städtetages und
oberbürgermeister von leipzig hallo herr
jung
hallo guten abend sie hatten ja vor zwei
wochen auch eine ähnliche situation in
etwas größerer dimension da waren nicht
400 menschen auf der straße sondern
mehrere tausend die rede war von über
20.000 menschen die in leipzig durch die
innenstadt zogen und als erhalten
wahrscheinlich 40 45 also wirklich große
zahlen die da durch die innenstadt zogen
was ist denn da eigentlich erst in der
retrospektive aus ihrer sicht schief
gelaufen
na ja wir hatten wir hatten sehr
dezidiert gesagt wir versuchen
versammlungsrecht zu wahren und
angeboten vor den toren der stadt bei
der neuen messe auf den parkplätzen
diese große innovation zu ermöglichen
natürlich unter den bedingungen der
korona verordnung aber leider das
oberverwaltungsgericht dann unseren
strich durch die rechnung gemacht und
diese demonstration in der innenstadt
genehmigt angeblich wegen der genügend
vorhandenen fläche wir sind sehr sehr
unglücklich gewesen mussten das
vollziehen und dem ergebnis waren so
viele dass in der tat sowohl unser
ordnungsamt als auch die polizei die
lage nicht mehr so einschätzen konnten
um dann
groß auch die colonia verordnung
umzusetzen sondern die
verhältnismäßigkeit der mittel
diskutiert wurde und am ende leider
polizei über land wurde und corona
leugner hooligans auch rechtsradikale
sich auf den straßen in bewegung gesetzt
haben es war unerträglich
jetzt kommen verschärfte maßnahmen für
landkreisen mit höheren zahlen
befürchten sie da wieder ähnliche
bewegungen ähnliche proteste natürlich
gibt es menschen die das nicht
akzeptieren es gibt
verschwörungstheorien es gibt leugner es
gibt die unterschiedlichsten menschen
die die aus unterschiedlichsten
motivationen heraus dass alles ablehnen
und ich glaube wir müssen kommunizieren
wir müssen immer wieder erklären um was
es eigentlich geht es geht wirklich um
den schutz von leben und nicht die
differenzierung acht der ist doch ein
älterer mensch und da muss man doch
nicht so drauf achten nein das
grundgesetz sagt jedes leben ist gleich
lebenswert und leben muss geschützt
werden und das müssen wir vermitteln und
cordula ist kein spaß und das ist nicht
erfunden und das ist auch nicht
irgendwann da war es eine verschwörung
von irgendwelchen großindustriellen oder
von bill gates den usa sondern es ist
die konkrete bezogen in der tat
insbesondere von menschen die risiko
behaftet sind die um nun schwächen haben
die clips vorerkrankungen haben übrigens
nicht nur die eltern sondern auch
jüngere sind betroffen
und wenn wir das nicht klar machen das
deutlich herausarbeiten dann werden wir
nicht ruhe hinein kriegen also ich
plädiere dafür und das sind uns alle
einig alle oberbürgermeister den
bürgermeister in dieser stadt in diesem
staat wir sind uns sehr sehr einig wir
müssen diese maßnahmen vorziehen die
kontakte beschränken damit unser
gesundheitssystem das überhaupt
bewältigen kann und am ende des weges
werden wir das schaffen mit impfsystem
mit vernünftigen aha regeln werden wir
im nächsten premieren ganzen schritt
weiter sein
das freut mich dass sie so optimistisch
sind hier sind viele menschen bei uns in
den kommentaren entweder nicht so
optimistisch machen sich sorgen
beschweren sich darüber dass maßnahmen
nicht eingehalten werden dass menschen
sich nicht an zum beispiel die aha
regeln halten andere das haben kennen
wir aus unserem streams die sich mit
geholt
heftigen sind fleißig dabei entweder
tatsächlich dieses vorkommen zu leugnen
dazu sagen dass gebe keine pandemie
das können wir so nicht stehen lassen
das sind tatsächlich wissenschaftlich
gesicherte tatsachen auch wenn man das
immer wieder versucht in den kommentaren
anders darzustellen
hier gibt es außerdem mal wieder eine
große diskussion um die frage was können
pcr test überhaupt nachweisen
es gibt beschwerden darüber dass wir von
infizierten sprechen wenn man eigentlich
wenn man es ganz streng genommen sind
von positiven test sprechen müsste die
kritik nehme ich jetzt mal mit aber ich
glaube eigentlich ist jedem klar was
gemeint ist fakt ist die zahlen steigen
der positiven test dementsprechend
steigen auch die zahlen der menschen die
im krankenhaus liegen
hier gibt es jetzt nochmal auf diese
demonstration zu kommen herr jung noch
mal verschiedene kritikpunkte einmal zum
beispiel dass es mir nicht möglich war
die menschen in der innenstadt
aufzuhalten aber dass es dann möglich
war zum beispiel die vorkommnisse in
connewitz woher die linke szene zu hause
ist bei ihnen dann da doch wieder
einzugreifen wäre wurde dann mit
verschiedenen maß gemessen also gibt es
tatsächlich dann wenn es um die
durchsetzung von maßnahmen gibt geht man
dahin wo man irgendwie noch die lage
versucht unter kontrolle zu kriegen weil
man das in der stadt nicht mehr nicht
mehr kontrolle kriegen konnte ja ich
kenne diesen vorwurf natürlich auch und
wir haben das intensiv ausgewertet auch
mit der polizei gesprochen ich glaube
dass wir auch das ist eine
verschwörungstheorie die nicht so stimmt
am ende des tages ging es darum die
verhältnismäßigkeit der mittel
einzuschätzen und vor ort dann an
anderer stelle auch zu zeigen dass man
dass man bereit ist dinge durchzusetzen
ein brand zu löschen der ansonsten durch
die feuerwehr nicht mehr zu löschen
gewesen wäre
ich glaube dass das ist vergossene milch
es geht jetzt darum beginn der debatte
zu führen
versammlungsrecht und recht auf
unversehrtheit miteinander abzuwägen tag
2 des grundgesetzes paragraph 8 des
grundgesetzes und die wussten sie tanja
albrecht das dass wir jetzt
ich glaube dass wir jetzt durch das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz eine bessere
handhabe haben deutlich zu machen dass
der schutz des lebens ein unglaublicher
stellen wird
und wir auch meine ich stufen planmäßig
agieren müssten das heißt ab bestimmten
inzidenz in der bestimmten
betroffenheiten und infektions lagen
muss man auch das versammlungsrecht in
gewisser weise einschränken einmal
denken oder abstand wird wir die ganz
gesamtlage nein abschaffen würde ich das
nicht nein das da das geht mir zu weit
aber wir haben heute sehr intensiv
diskutiert im hauptausschuss des
städtetags zu sagen ich kann nicht mehr
kommunizieren wenn eine innenstadt wo
wir ansonsten den einkaufszonen masken
wagen plötzlich zu einem ort wird wo
tausende sich ohne masse bewegen und das
alles leugnen und da müssen die
verhältnismäßigkeit wahren also
demonstrationsrecht bestimmten
größenordnung zu lassen aber bitte nicht
in unseren innenstädten werde ein weg
ein zweiter weg der in der tat darauf zu
setzen dass man seine meinung und seine
demonstrationsrecht auch wahrnehmen kann
ohne die große demonstration wir haben
heute so vielfältige möglichkeiten seine
meinung zu sagen dass die
meinungsvielfalt ist gegeben und ich
glaube insofern kann man auch über die
größenordnung einer demonstration über
den ort an der demonstration besser
steuern wir haben in sachsen jetzt klar
geregelt bis 1000 wird es in der regel
genehmigt natürlich unter auflagen
stationär und mit mund nasen bedeckung
aber ansonsten wir können nicht in den
das vollkommen frei lassen und
gleichzeitig solch kindern erklären dass
sie nicht mehr zusammen fußball spielen
dürfen
also sagt da passt etwas nicht zusammen
und das ist aber gar noch ein thema was
wir hier immer wieder besprechen und
immer wieder den kommentaren finden da
passt etwas nicht zusammen also wenn zum
beispiel sicher dass nur noch zwei
haushalte in der öffentlichkeit treffen
dürfe man aber auf dem spielplatz geht
und dort natürlich 5 bis 15 haushalte
vorfindet wenn es jetzt an weihnachten
wieder heißt man kann sich mit mehreren
haushalten treffen gleichzeitig aber
gastronomin geschlossen sind
ich lese hier in unseren kommentaren
viel unverständnis für die maßnahmen wir
haben sie bei ihnen nach der straße auch
gesehen wie erklären sie sich das ist es
tatsächlich dieses paradox dass dass das
tatsächlich jetzt in diesen maßnahmen
teilweise gibt oder ist es was ist ihre
erklärung dafür dass so viele menschen
sagen ich bin damit nicht einverstanden
ich kann sehr gut verstehen weil wir
noch besser erklären um was es
eigentlich geht es geht darum kontakte
zu minimieren
und natürlich sind die regeln die wir
auch bestellt haben die auch die
bundesregierung mit den
ministerpräsidenten aufstellt am letzten
im letzten am letzten ende in der
letzten konsequenz sind es willkürliche
regeln das heißt wir versuchen kontakte
zu minimieren und haben bestimmte
branchen bestimmte situationen
identifiziert um das am besten steuern
zu können
aber am ende sind es setzungen und das
muss man erklären wird keiner bestraft
hier wird nicht der gastronom bestraft
weil er ein schlechtes hygiene konzept
hat nein es geht darum dass weniger
menschen aus unterschiedlichen
richtungen zusammenkommen um insgesamt
die infektionsketten zu kontrollieren
und den gesundheitsämtern die chance zu
geben überhaupt nach zu verfolgen wo
kommen die infektion her und wir müssen
das ehrlich und offen diskutieren es
gibt es geht nicht um um ein ganz
gerechtes system sondern es geht darum
kontakte wirklich zu kontrollieren und
wenn wir das alle miteinander tun
deshalb auch im privaten bereich der
appell bitte bitte treffen sie sich
nicht mit vielen menschen sein macht es
überschaubar macht es klein
haltet durch ein paar monate und wir
können dann auch am ende des tages die
panini besiegen davon bin ich überzeugt
wenn sie von willkürlichen maßnahmen
sprechen oder von jeglichen setzungen
dieses ja nun mal sind wie sie es gerade
formuliert haben steckt da vielleicht
ein teil dieses unverständnisses mit
drin auch gerade dass man das gefühl hat
es gibt keinen masterplan keinen plan
der uns bis in die nächsten monate wird
den sommer führt ich darf man vergleich
wagen schauen sie wir haben festgelegt
im innerörtlichen verkehr davon auto 150
fahren das ist eine regel eine setzung
die hat der gesetzgeber willkürlich
festgelegt er hätte auch 40 oder 60
sagen können aber haben es auf 50
geeinigt und genau so ist es eigentlich
mit diesen bestimmungen in dieser corona
pandemischen situation
wir versuchen mit bestimmten regelungen
grenzen zu setzen um die ausbreitung des
virus zu verhindern um insgesamt die die
die kontrolle zu bewahren über diese
pandemie situation und das müssen wir
kommunizieren wir müssen viel ehrlicher
unklarer auch darüber sprechen und das
hat natürlich folgen für den gastronomen
für das konzert für den sportverein und
für all die die die bitteren pillen die
wir dabei schlucken
wissen aber ich glaube dass die setzung
sowie im straßenverkehr eine sinnvolle
maßnahme ist als grund verbot um
insgesamt herr der lage zu bleiben oder
wieder zu werden
ich lese gerade mal noch mal bei auf
youtube in den kommentaren das sind
jetzt ehrlich gesagt keine sachen die
sie beantworten können als politiker das
sind eher fragen an virologen aber da
lese ich zum beispiel den masken
schützen wie sie ihren abstand den
abstand schützt die sodann massen wenn
beide schützt wieso dann locker und das
hat auch die bundeskanzlerin aber
gestern noch mal genauer erläutert und
das haben uns auch virologen immer
wieder genauer erläutert ist das halt
maßnahmenpaket und keiner davon greift
allein ich glaube das ist tatsächlich
immer noch ein kommunikationsproblem
jetzt wollen wir eigentlich darüber
reden die man die maßnahmen umsetzen
kann und durchsetzen kann
das war eigentlich unsere gesprächsthema
wir sind so ein bisschen abgekommen weil
es doch immer wieder sehr spannend ist
zu schauen wie sich wer das erklärt dass
es diese skepsis gibt deswegen schauen
wir doch einmal darauf hat gestern
beschlossen wo sie nochmal
zusammenfassend das hat meine kollegin
nina niebergall gemacht und danach hin
wir darüber wie man das überhaupt
durchsetzen könnte
ab erster dezember gelten neue kontakt
beschränkungen dann dürfen sich nur noch
fünf personen treffen aus zwei
verschiedenen haushalten ausgenommen
kinder bis 14
das gilt zu hause und in der
öffentlichkeit die masken pflicht wird
verschärft maske auf heißt es in zukunft
auch unter freiem himmel
überall dort wo in innenstädten viele
menschen zusammenkommen
auch auf parkplätzen und vor
supermärkten für geschäfte gibt es neue
auflagen in kleineren läden gilt ein
kunde oder eine kundin auf zehn
quadratmeter in großen geschäften muss
mehr platz sein
20 quadratmeter pro kunde oder kunden
und auch silvester wird etwas anders auf
belebten straßen und plätzen heißt es da
feuerwerk verboten
lasst uns also jetzt beschlossene sache
herr jung vertretend für den deutschen
städte bund der hat heute in der
pressemitteilung beschrieben oder
gestern nacht noch sie halten die
verlängerung des lockdown leid für eine
richtige maßnahme
sie sprechen aber auch von der schweren
einschränkungen für die menschen das ist
aber die große frage wie lässt sich das
überhaupt alles kontrollieren herr jung
sehen sie die städte dafür ausreichend
aufgestellt
also erstens gehört dazu eine
selbstverantwortung und eine akzeptanz
in der bevölkerung und wenn ich das
sagen darf die überwiegende große
mehrheit der menschen sowohl in leipzig
also auch in anderen städten dieser
republik hält sich sehr wohl daran dass
ist das erste dass zwei dieser tat wenn
man etwas ankündigten wenn der staat
regeln aufstellt dann muss er sie auch
durchsetzen das heißt unser
ordnungsämter in zusammenarbeit der
polizei sind aufgefordert hier sehr klar
unser deutlich in die in die straße zu
gehen auf den platz zu gehen in die
geschäfte zu gehen zu kontrollieren und
das tun wir auch und wir tun es hand in
hand und das hat sich mittlerweile gut
eingespielt dass das miteinander von
ordnung sendern polizei funktioniert ich
bin dafür dass wir immer nur diese regel
aufstellen die man wirklich auch
durchsetzen und dann auch kontrollieren
kann und ich glaube dass wir hier ein
verfahren gefunden haben wo das halbwegs
austariert ist dass in diesen bereich
setzen wir auf die eigenverantwortung
was kriegen sie dann von ihren
polizeibeamten in leipzig gespiegelt
wenn da kontrolliert wird und man trifft
auf menschen die sich nicht an die
regeln halten
geht es dagegen wer oder gibt es ein
sicht es gibt überwiegend einsicht aber
natürlich gibt es im einzelfall auch den
der der unbelehrbare sein recht auf
freiheit fordert und dabei vergisst dass
seine freiheit seine grenze findet in
der freiheit des anderen menschen also
kurzum konsequentes verhalten
konsequente anzeigen von
ordnungswidrigkeiten
das muss schon sein das ist wie im
straßenverkehr ich bemühe mich als
beispiel noch mal zu bringen
wenn wir beide den den autofahrer fahren
lassen und nicht ertappen
dann haben wir schlechte karten dann
haben der bild beste auf unseren straßen
das heißt regeln müssen kontrolliert
werden und das werden wir auch das sind
uns einig das werden wir miteinander
auch sehr sehr konsequent tun müssen
aber lässt sich das zum beispiel an
silvester überhaupt durchsetzt und wenn
wir dann daran denken das haben wir es
gibt es die regel keinen feuerwerk an
öffentlichen plätzen wenn da trotzdem
dann ein paar tausend menschen
zusammenkommen und anfangen mit den
bürgern zu werfen da ist doch eine
polizei hilflos überfordert
ich denke wir müssen vorsorge treffen
erstens müssen wir aufklären ich setze
darauf dass viele menschen sich daran
halten
und dann geht es dann darum die sperren
wir diese plätze ab ja ich bin in der
tat der meinung wir tun gut daran
übrigens auch aus einem zweiten grund
wir brauchen die verletzung und der der
silvesternacht nicht zur gleichzeitig
nicht gleichzeitig in unseren
krankenhäusern zu behandeln wir haben
dort genug zu tun und ganz andere
aufgaben ich glaube wir schaffen das wir
kriegen das hin an belebten plätzen dann
müssen wir eben abgetan
dort muss streife gegangen werden und
ich hoffe dass insgesamt ist akzeptiert
wird und verstanden wird
ich habe das gefühl die bald über 70
prozent der menschen versteht sehr wohl
in welcher situation wir sind
ich habe mir mal interessanter
kommentare auf facebook zum beispiel von
carola rabl drastischer polizeieinsatz
und sofortige auflösung dieser das ist
jetzt zitat schraubenköpfe demos das ist
der einzige weg diese spieler von der
straße zu bekommen das ist inzwischen
sogar ein akt der notwehr
sie fordert jetzt wirklich wasser marsch
und knüppel frei ist das eine forderung
der sie sich anschließen würden
naja so würde ich das nicht formulieren
ich setze ich das glaub ich aber jetzt
gespräche und dass man den maßen her
aber im prinzip das ja ich kann nicht
verordnungen erlassen und die dann nicht
durchsetzen ich glaube wir sind gut
beraten als staat dann auch gesicht zu
zeigen ansonsten verliert der staat auch
seine seine glaubwürdigkeit ich habe
mich sehr geärgert das ist uns nicht
gelungen ist zu verhindern dass
hooligans über den ring marschieren und
und dann den schuh buch von 1989 auf
ihren lippen führen das ist schon
schmerzhaft und das muss man unterbinden
da muss man klar sein und ich denke dass
die einsicht auch zunehmend in
deutschland wächst es gab ja auch schon
bei großen demonstrationen zum beispiel
die maßnahme dass die polizei die
funkzellen abgefragt um festzustellen
welche mobiltelefone vor ort sind und
dann tatsächlich die menschen zuordnen
zu können ist das in der maßnahme über
die sie nachdenken würden wenn sich so
eine situation wieder an wand oder zum
beispiel an silvester wenn sie wissen
die innenstadt könnte vor laufen wir
müssen gucken dass wir uns da irgendwie
vorbereiten
sie stellen natürlich jetzt ganz ganz
schwierige rechtliche fragen dadurch
nicht ich glaube wir haben mittlerweile
schon
ich glaube schon wir haben mittlerweile
die möglichkeit ich habe gerade letzten
samstag im lagezentrum der polizei
verbracht wir haben durch durch
kameraaufnahmen durch überfliegen durch
fest installierte kamera sehr wohl die
möglichkeit das gesamt
demonstrationsgeschehen zu überblicken
und auch einzugreifen und auch sehr
aktuell
die die die einsatzbereitschaft und die
einsatz die einsätze zu koordinieren
wir brauchen dafür keine
funkzellenabfragen aber ja wir müssen
kontrollieren das gehört zur wahl dazu
denn wir sind es habe ich den
pathetischen satz vielleicht einmal
formulieren
in einer demokratie sind wir ganz
besonders in besonderer weise den
schwächsten verpflichtet und es geht um
den schutz der schwächsten die in dieser
personalsituation sie eben nicht werden
können und ich finde es unglaublich und
unsolidarisch wenn ich sozusagen mich
darüber hinwegsetzen sagen jeder seines
glückes schmied nein ist
ich wir haben ja tatsächlich auch
sanktionen ein großes maßnahmenpaket ein
großes bußgeld paket das je nach
bundesland unterschiedlich aussieht
mein kollege benno krieger hat mal
zusammengefasst wie das in sachsen zum
beispiel ist wer sich unerlaubt in
größeren gruppen trifft oder den
mindestabstand nicht einhält zahlt 150
euro bei missachtung der massen pflicht
ist das bußgeld geringer besonders teuer
kann es für betriebe werden wenn sie
mindestabstand und masken pflicht nicht
durchsetzen droht eine strafe von 500
euro bei der masken pflicht gilt
bundesweit mindestens 50 euro als
strafzahlung
sachsen liegt mit 60 euro leicht darüber
in anderen bundesländern sind durch
bußgeld spannen höhere strafen möglich
in berlin kann ein verstoß gegen die
masken pflicht bis zu 500 euro kosten
eine ausnahme bildet sachsen anhalt dort
können landkreise und städte selbst über
geldbußen entscheiden
eine andere frage ist wie konsequent die
strafen durchgesetzt werden
in leipzig haben bereits mehrere tausend
menschen gegen die korona maßnahmen
demonstriert zum vergleich die stadt hat
seit märz nur 1343 bußgeldbescheide
erlassen
die bußgeld summe beläuft sich auf knapp
200.000 euro ja das sind zahlen die
werden sie kennen herr jung als
oberbürgermeister von leipzig aber auch
als präsident des deutschen städtetages
das liest sich jetzt erst mal viel aber
im endeffekt man überlegt wie viele
menschen sie in leipzig haben dann ist
es doch wird die summe gesehen doch
nicht mehr so viel oder warum gibt es
nicht noch mehr bußgelder oder noch mehr
durchgreifende maßnahmen also
demonstration ist ein wirklich
schlechtes beispiel weil in der tat das
gehört zur wahl dazu die polizeikräfte
und auch die ordnungskräfte in der
situation überfordert waren die masse
einfach so groß war dass man da nicht
mehr agieren konnte aber in der tat
unter jährlich unter der woche bei den
konsolen wird das sehr konsequent
angebot
angewendet und sie müssen sich immer
vorstellen dann wird jemand angesprochen
der sec die maske nicht dann zieht er
sie doch in dem moment auch wenn die
konsole kommt man versucht zu ermahnen
versucht zuzusprechen mal versucht zu
kommunizieren und ich habe in der tat
auch mal ein ordnungsamtsmitarbeiter die
die devise mit gegen bitte sprecht erst
mal versucht zu überzeugen versucht in
die kommunikation zu kommen bevor man zu
dieser ordnungswidrigkeit greift ich
setz kraft es ist ein wir wollen doch
nicht wir wollen damit nicht geld
einnehmen sondern möchten leben schützen
insofern ist am sinnvollsten immer
wieder der die ermahnung der appell und
die ordnungswidrigkeit und das bußgeld
muss die letzte die der letzte weg sein
ist meine feste überzeugung sind denn
diese sanktionen in ihren augen
ausreichend
ich denke schon dass es wird ich denke
schon dass es wirkt auch die quarantäne
die wir kontrollieren auch dort kann es
ja empfindliche geldstrafen geben in der
regel viele viele menschen sind doch bei
der ermahnung dann oftmals erschrocken
oder ändern ihr verhalten ja der ein
oder andere das ist sozusagen tun und
dann sobald der ordnungshüter um die
ecke ist sich wieder anders entscheiden
aber echten ich bleibe dabei ich setze
auf einsichtig setzt auf kommunikation
ist jetzt auf gespräche und bin immer
noch der guten hoffnung dass wir doch
die überwiegende mehrzahl der menschen
so besser erreichen als mit dem mit dem
knüppel der eben in dem youtube
kommentar angeführt wurde dann danke ich
ihnen herr jung und hoffen wir dass sie
bei dieser einsicht dass sie diese
ansicht nicht irgendwann bereuen
wir werden schauen was an weihnachten
passiert dort wurde auch schon
angekündigt es wird nicht in den
wohnungen kontrolliert wie viele
menschen zusammenkommen also da auch der
appell der politiker jung vielen dank
heute abend dass sie sich zeit genommen
haben wir uns ich danke ihnen danke
schön
ja und hier in den kommentaren geht es
nach wie vor hoch her das sind muss ich
sagen ja mittlerweile die üblichen
kommentare wo angezweifelt wird dass es
eine pandemie ist dass es genug
infizierte gibt
ich glaube ich musste einfach nochmal
jetzt auch wenn ich die maßnahmen der
politik jetzt persönlich
auch als bürger nicht unter immerhin
einstellen gutheiße und verstehe doch
noch mal darauf hinweisen dass die
politik doch die maßnahmen ergriffen hat
nicht weil es um zahlen geht sondern
weil es darum geht die überlastung des
gesundheitssystems zu verhindern und das
ist tatsächlich eine sorge die glaube
ich viele menschen antreibt in diesem
sinne machen wir den chat und diesen
stream für heute abend aber erst mal zu
wir werden uns auf jeden fall wieder
sehen wahrscheinlich schon morgen bis
dahin sage ich schönen abend noch vielen
dank fürs dabeisein und tschüss